come on oh my goodness hi sir we
required this is crazy I haven't seen
you in so long Hi how are you
why are you wearing the most like hard
to be pregnant in an outfit I know
that's so anti-pregnancy dude I broke
into my major life rules today I'm
wearing a denim jumpsuit and I went to a
Galleria are you showing are you due
soon what's going on I need to know
everything are you crowning what's going
on why are you spreading your legs
that's what's happening so yeah so I'm
four
I know it's so funny I'm four months six
I don't know why as soon as you're
pregnant everything's in weeks I'm so
dyslexic about it yeah I'm not sure
exactly but I'm like four and a half
months it's got a penis
that's all I know I just say the
funniest thing you did was when you when
we were at your party and you were like
you showed me that you were like I was
like oh my God and you were eating more
than I've ever seen you eat
and then um you like you had this same
thing like a thing that's around your
neck like mine and you showed me the
sonogram and you're like don't tell
anyone and then you forgot to close it
and you were walking around with the
sonogram open over your uterus around I
was like Whitney turn it off we're out
the party I was like I don't want anyone
to know about it
oh hello slugs it's me in Vegas on my
birthday doing my favorite thing playing
slots I want you to make like a buffalo
and herd your way over the region
theater on August 4th where we are doing
a trash Tuesday live show a lot could go
down a lot could go wrong actually
that's what I meant to say so you can
get tickets to the link below this video
do not miss this please go get your
tickets now I can't wait to meet you to
interact with you to squeeze you so find
a ticket link get your tickets now and
I'll see you there
this show is sponsored by betterhelp let
therapy be your map with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com trash Tuesday go to
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday to
find out how to get your hands on new
simply spiked Peach that's
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday
flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply Spike Co
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked as a trademark
of the Simply Orange Juice company stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday hi you guys I am officially on
tour and you can get tickets to see my
stand-up in Oxnard DC Boston Madison
Wisconsin San Diego Detroit Chicago San
Jose Irvine and more and you can get
tickets at Esther onice.com and make
sure you check out my new podcast with
Rick last it's called Rick and Esther
have a time and that is exactly what we
do
hey sluggies I am so excited you can
come see me this weekend in South
Carolina and Greenville at the comedy
zone that's July 28th and 29th I'll be
in Philadelphia August 11th and 12th
I'll be in Calgary for The Great
Outdoors Comedy Festival August 27th and
I'll be in San Francisco in September
and Austin in October you can see all of
my tickets and all of my sales at
annieleterman.com shows check me out
every Thursday on anniewood love you
guys can't wait to see you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
are you keeping it you know what I don't
know I've been in Texas a lot so I've
been going to Rogan's Club so I sort of
missed my window I had the first three
trimesters for three weeks in Austin but
yeah I think we're keeping it it's all
happening are we gonna make a Instagram
for it no like Marshall yeah
wait have you had like how are you like
are you sick are you is there any are
you fine I feel great I I have a hot
take pregnancy is not that hard what
it's not that hard it's you know I don't
I think that being a touring comedian
it's that's the worst yeah exactly I
think maybe just the bar is pretty low
for us in terms of like physical Comfort
but I was on the road I didn't find out
for 10 weeks I am the dumb [__] that
had no idea what is that so you didn't
even feel the nausea of like the first
couple I would say touring in
Saskatchewan I was like nauseous I was
tired but I just like did for 10 whole
weeks guys
I just kind of was like I'm always kind
of nauseous and tired these days I was
like eating out of vending machines I'm
glad I didn't notice though because I
guess like week three to ten are the
most high risk for miscarriage so like
stressing out I probably would have been
you know stressed or you know something
so I just like totally didn't even
notice no you were just producing like
40 roasts yeah exactly they are still
re-editing she's like the coolest thing
about only fans is you can still edit
now and I'm like with the end
she sent me like new edits all the time
like Winnie this is insanity I really
that was a really big part of my deal
with only fans TV is that if I deliver
on a deadline and I see something later
that makes my Virgo brain go crazy I can
re-upload it so there was like an open
like I want to do this custom open that
was in front of a green screen and all
this like cool animated stuff and we
couldn't finish in time to make because
it was very important to me that it
aired on Mother's Day yeah to make sure
that my dead mother was just like this
suicidal is brave for what I was airing
and um so we did it and then uh uploaded
it on time and then later added it
uploaded and then I would like see stuff
in the edit that I was just like ah like
that just doesn't sound good let's
change it there was a couple um because
I was pregnant at the time I was editing
it and you do get a little mom brain I
mean you you have a vampire eating your
brain and there were every reaction shot
of Dan Levy was completely out of focus
on that first edit that you would have
seen like he's just out of focus for no
reason and
um so we uh re-uploaded basically to
clean it all up later did you um have a
preference for the sex of the baby I'm
gonna say something that is just is what
it is I am shocked by how sexist I was
when I found out it was a boy because I
was like okay it's gonna be what it is
and for some reason like you kind of go
like I guess it's a girl I don't know
why because it's like you know and then
the text just said boy and I was like
[__] like I I pumped
100 sure that yeah everybody would only
make a boy yeah that's so a lot of
people say they're like you're a boy Mom
that's you know I think it was more this
number one I'm afraid with a girl I
would project my [__] onto them like I
was just you're afraid of that that's
the only reason I want a kid are you
kidding me I only want a girl for that
reason I see my girlfriends that have
daughters they're in a dog fight they're
in a nightmare the idea of me destroying
my body for you and you're gonna talk to
me like
pinch you at Trader Joe's like I will
I'm gonna be a Pinchy mom dude
I was a pinched baby pinched my whole
leg it works how successful you are look
at her cheekbones we need to bring back
a little child abuse my mom used to
purple nurple like just just twist it in
public at a JCPenney and I'd walk around
with blue titties we call them pennies
but okay oh fancy JC is what you would
do if you didn't want to go somewhere
with your mom in public you would just
sit on the ground yeah you know what I
mean she would pinch me behind the ear
all the way to the car that [__] works
is that still legal I'm doing it I
wasn't pissed armpits because you don't
really bruise there that much oh smart
yeah yeah just find them in the places
that aren't so like obvious and also I
think that I'm just too sensitive to
babies dressing sexy now it drives me
nuts like people are like boys shouldn't
dress like girls girls shouldn't dress
like boys little girls shouldn't dress
like little girls
the mini skirts target has a gay section
who gives a [__] have you you've seen
the I tried to buy a bathing suit for my
kid friend's kid they bikinis for their
only bikini yeah so sexy but sexy and
then the the what is it the christening
outfits I don't think I'm doing that
they're just wedding dresses
with like veils the fact that you're
even considering that you were like I
don't think I'm gonna Christmas my baby
the fact that you've thought about
Christening well you know what I'm
saying I'm just saying I'm not gonna
probably be in the market for
christening dresses but I just you know
that I'm haunted you gotta have a breath
why are you saying Jessica McClintock
sent like a certain feeling down my body
yeah what a throwback that was a that
was a real moment but I I I I just
pictured all these gifts for a girl
coming in and my friends giving me like
mini skirts for I mean I could have just
borrowed your clothes
um but uh and just being like oh what so
my baby's supposed to wear many like I
just I you know that I have like some
weird connection with Shirley Temple
where I feel the need to like make
things right with what was done to her
the fact that our our business weirdest
sentence ever I have a connection with
Shirley Temple yeah I do I'm just
shocked it wasn't you saying something
for me no but do you remember like
during like me too everyone was like is
Hollywood creepy I'm like you mean the
business that was built on the back of a
four-year-old toddler named Shirley
Temple who was twerking on men on
steamboats there were no parents and
there was no moms there's no Nancy they
were she was like at war with soldiers
like dancing and it was just like wild
dude have you seen Shirley Temple in
blackface dude they did her very dirty I
have a like okay so I've always wanted a
girl I'm so fixated on having a girl
only I really want to know like if I can
even express the grief I want to express
if it turns out I could have a boy
because let me ask you a question if I
if it had said girl would I have had the
same reaction I don't know I'm so much
takes over biologically and I think that
like I always just assumed I would have
a girl I feel like my in my life being
in any kind of therapy trauma therapy
every work piece of work I've done on
myself is to break these ancestral
cycles for when I have a girl yeah I'm
saying so it was like I always just
pictured having a girl but then it was
boy and I was like oh but I think there
was a little bit of like me I if I have
two I want her to have an older brother
like the best thing for the girl is to
have an older brother so I think I also
thought of the boy in terms of an older
brother right away because I had an
older brother and I think that really
helped me in a lot of ways and I guess
it's just like I've always thought that
way too and for some reason I'm just
like is bringing a girl into this world
right now like is that something I'm
rooting for if it happens great but
there was just I think it was just
relief not excitement I was like okay
this is gonna be a lot easier maybe at
least like not on my house right yeah I
mean but maybe emotionally I'm not like
I have a friend who missed you does my
hair extension said that she like
literally got in a confrontation with
somebody she's got a daughter who's like
15 and she like walked into Jamba Juice
and like guys were looking at her and
she was like excuse me do you have a
like she went I would just go nuts yeah
you know what I'm saying yeah so I I or
not I think one once you actually get
pregnant you're like oh I'm so much
Chiller about this than I thought I
would and your brain kind of just starts
taking over you know like I always had
weird [__] with my body and eating stuff
and like I literally haven't thought
about calories I haven't thought about
my body you look really good you look
[__] hot nice by the way Nothing fits
and I'm like that's so cool he's growing
instead of like things don't fit by the
way though when I saw you at the party
you looked really really good and so
when you said you were pregnant I was
like oh my God but also found out like
20 minutes before that's gonna sound
really weird but like I feel like a
sexual connection to you are you're gay
now right because that's the new thing
I'm not gay both of you I'm like one of
the straightest girls yeah I was dating
a girl when I found out I was pregnant
conversation
I'm glad with Whitney and then all of a
sudden I looked over I was like is
Whitney just like straddling a woman
making out there we were all like trying
to act normal by the way that one I told
Dave that you had a that you were dating
a woman and he keeps asking me he's like
has Whitney told her girlfriend she's
pregnant yet
I don't know her by the way I was
hanging out with Whitney all day at the
the party for the Burt roast and we're
up in your hotel room and there was just
this hot girl that and you always kind
of have someone that's very comfortable
like that I haven't met yet so I'm like
did she hire a new assistant like I
don't know you always have someone
that's like Cara in your purse or going
for yourself I do not you do but it's
like they usually work for you yeah oh
yeah yeah do you know what I mean so I
have a name
I'm going through her things that's me
she's doing it for like L Magazine
online you know it's one of the more ice
I don't have any of that anymore I
decided not to do an assistant not to do
it I'm just like how do you break it to
your
um girl lover that you're pregnant well
a malignant narcissist told her without
me being able to get to it first so it
was a nightmare but um you know it just
yeah it happened it happened it happens
but um It's Tricky I mean I think I was
listening that you were maybe talking to
girls or hanging out with girls or
something and you weren't sure if you
were gay or not you'd know if you're gay
if you can get through an eight minute
voice memo I'm a girl I would get to
like four and a half minutes and I'd be
like I guess I'm not gay
I'm not gay it's just like I as someone
that leaves voice memos eight minutes it
was back at the time where if you listen
to half of it and had to do something
start over yeah that is the worst yes
oh God no I'm still in the trial and
error um phase you know like I've been
on two dates with girls I made out with
two girls and um there isn't a whole lot
of blood flow happening when I'm making
out but like I I'm still trying to push
past the feeling of not feeling super
horny when we're making out interesting
I also think it's probably the person
too because it's like I think for me
when I'm attracted to a girl it's like
that girl or that guy like there's
something about them but think maybe
they're recreating some childhood thing
or adrenaline thing or something but I
can't like force myself I'm just I'm not
like which by the way is better can you
imagine just being attracted to all guys
or all girls it's very specific what
kind of a woman are you attracted to
I've been trying to figure this out
I was like Wendy's making out with
herself what the hell is going on wait
was it your way it looks like Whitney
that's like basically was it your
Whitney doll
she now I can't afford her
um I I don't think she looks like me but
a lot of people did say that you had the
vibe wait okay so I I sorry Esther is
gonna hurt your feelings but I'm not
attracted to short girls
[Music]
like that guys want to be able to
spinner I think that for me you know I
think as as I whatever as come to terms
with that like we're emotional people
we're sensitive we're emotional and
there's something so hot about not
watching someone's face glaze over
when you're talking about like yeah I
had my feelings hurt by this and I don't
know why what did they mean by this
comment and the person you're with is
like huh what do they mean like and
there's something like really hot about
not having someone like roll their eyes
while you're talking about something
hard that happened you know so that is
really hot about being with a girl you
know someone's like yeah let's pick this
Instagram comment apart for two and a
half yeah they're locked in yeah and
they're not thinking you're crazy or
stupid you're not feeling like you know
um you're being a psycho or obsessive
they don't pathologize you you know and
then it gets tricky though because a
week later then they're doing that to
your text and you're like God damn it
you know so dating a woman is also very
educational because you realize how you
come off to guys yeah you realize you're
like oh okay I got it now
um but it's kind of nice to not feel
crazy you know it's kind of nice to not
feel like you know to feel validated
yeah or just to like feel like you said
something and they heard it yeah you
know what I mean or to have someone be
like oh I remember you're allergic to
Dairy
after six months I'm not gonna keep you
know what I mean just like little things
kind of like that now are we allowed to
ask or is there any kind of reveals
about the babies
father is that like a conversation he's
just he's literally a guy he's a
hillbilly from North Carolina ever I
thought I was Baron dude when I met him
he was in a Spider-Man costume there was
a guy
following around with like uh many files
I don't know what the file and they were
like spilling out of his hand and I go
what's that and you go I'll explain it
later to be fair you were wearing a
press that is out of tits
it was Halloween I buried the queen it
was Halloween it is but I did not see a
face there was just a figure that
completely masked figure yeah it was
like some Halloween thing and I and yeah
and he was like so redressing up or
something and I was like ah go for it he
came out of full Spider-Man costume
by the way he's 15. we forgot to tell
you guys that's great great correct and
so um uh yeah that's so funny he's uh
like a Star Wars dork computer
programmer
um I was like I don't I'm not gonna call
you baby daddy like what should I call
you he's a Star Wars dork he was like uh
what about Lord Vader
instead of baby's father wow he's like
funny and and just like he's a computer
programmer he's a nerd nerd this is what
we do this works hot nerd this is him in
a nutshell he you know I was having
family driving family somewhere or
something and um I know that's a
sentence that never comes out of my
mouth I'm trying to like reconnect with
uncles and stuff and um
that's all you guys over connected
um and uh and I had dogs in the car and
I was like you know what let's just
there's a service where you can have
someone come watch your car it's like 70
bucks let's just do that tomorrow and
then at 11 o'clock at night I couldn't
find him and couldn't find him I go
outside he's vacuuming the car fully
washing the car and I was like what are
you doing and he was like I just can't
stand the idea of another man washing
your car
well how about a woman washing her [__]
Southern like this traditional gender
roles this is my job and I find that
very hot
there was a guy that I was recently
dating and um I had a task rabbit come
into the home I didn't even like ask him
to assemble the TV and he was like I
have to leave he's like I'm so sorry I
can't be here and I'm like what is it
that bad he's like I cannot be as a man
I cannot sit here and watch another man
do a job that was I could have easily
done why didn't you come to me first
this is the opposite he left me and Dave
we have like these all these hot men
that come and like hang frames and like
Joe
yeah we just sit there we're both like
sharing the CPAP
sometimes I like Dave like should I be
[__] that guy like what am I doing it
wrong and we just we yeah it's fine
y'all have been together almost 10 years
right yeah that is so wild I know it's
crazy how's Esther King going uh well I
went back and we went back and people
think why people thought you got married
first of all then did they think you got
divorced no I don't think they think
much it I changed my name basically as a
joke for a bit
um so more on that later but no we're
we're just I'm just thinking in terms of
taking names what to name this baby like
it's it's well I actually wanted to ask
you like today I met Dave King this is
Esther King well now that you're you
recently found out you're Jewish I think
that easy I think that what you have to
do and I am saying you have to is name
your baby with the same first letter as
the name of one of your parents since
they have recently passed away
I don't know what those letters I have
to be reminded of those people yes you
have to honor them that's the Jewish
I was gonna say Eric and fatty I think
that your baby's name has to start with
one of those letters Esther pavitz I
want to name him Hawkeye so I don't know
if that's gonna work it could be the
middle name that's great I'm dead
serious
so that's a Jewish tradition another
Jewish tradition circumcision what are
we doing are we doing that still no yeah
I'm not doing it anymore I don't I don't
it seems mutilated it's okay so I come
from a country where if you are not
circumcised you are humiliated right
they call you this term called and if
what is it
like the
set that's inside your pee yeah it's
kind of like a rite of passage and they
don't circumcise babies a lot in like
the certain provinces they don't do the
glomco clamp like up front with their
babies so they do it when they're seven
years old and it's a holy ritual you do
as a community they like they put it's
more embarrassing it's [__] up it's
crazy so like
um I have this idea growing up that I'm
like oh if you're not circumcised like
you're just kind of lesser of a man
right but I've had a whole change of
heart about it I'm like I don't think
that I could physically like I want him
to make that decision for himself right
right
um but as women like do we have that
reaction still with circumcised or
non-circumcised dudes I mean there's a
lot of metrics coming in that it it's
about the way it's done that it can be
really traumatic because it's like
imagine the first primary trauma of your
life having your dick cut off like and
your mom gives you to a stranger to for
the biggest pain of your life and then
everyone starts clapping like it is
they're now the rabbi like sucks the
blood out or whatever they do I don't
know exactly I don't know if they do it
anymore because I think they were giving
them her they look yeah
foreign
this show is sponsored by betterhelp and
I have to say I've got a lot going on up
here there's anxiety there's low
feelings there's red dread is a big
theme in my life and having someone to
talk to is a really key part of my
growth and my healing and Whitney is not
always available so not always or Dr
Drew whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement trusting yourself to make
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets and if you're
thinking of starting therapy you should
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule you
just fill up a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no cost no additional charge
and what we love the most about
betterhelp is it's such an easy first
step into therapy you don't have to
drive find parking do all this research
through you know better help handles all
the hard parts for you and they have a
little Journal feature which I love that
I can jot down my heaviest thoughts in
between my appointments that I can bring
up in my next therapy oh yeah when I was
rolling around last night I had to put
my little notes in gotta remember this
for tomorrow oh my goodness let therapy
be your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com trash Tuesday
what do you say that life is more
exciting when there are peaches involved
Annie oh you know I love Peaches I love
peaches and cream that's my favorite 112
song I love that song we got a 112 out
we have to have a sleepover by the way
and we will be drinking this during our
sleepover and we will be
this is such a tasty summer drink I've
been having my little you know fancy
single summer how do you say it it's a
single girl summer single girl summer
I've been having my fancy single girl
summer and this has been my go-to drink
it's really refreshing
um and um yeah they have they don't just
have Peach they have mango peach they
have a couple other really good flavors
they have a variety pack which has all
four of their fresh new flavors
signature Peach strawberry peach kiwi
Peach and mango peach and simply spiked
Peach is the newest addition to the
simply spiked family joining simply
spiked lemonade which broke the internet
when it dropped last summer with its
four bold and refreshing flavors
signature lemonade strawberry lemonade
blueberry lemonade and watermelon
lemonade and all flavors of Simply Spike
are crafted with five percent ABV and
five percent real fruit juice squeezed
then concentrated you know Peach it
gives like everybody that cute girly
Vibe I don't know I just like that for
my summer that's gonna be my summer
color peach and you can go to
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday to
find out how to get your hands on new
simply spiked Peach that's
drinksimplyspiked.com trash Tuesday
flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply spico
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked as a trademark
of the Simply Orange Juice company
[Music]
wait I also have to ask a question like
almost for advice as someone who is
still uncertain if they want children I
thought you're obviously uncircumcised
yeah
myself I was uncertain until I was
certain you know what I mean I was like
I was date not dating fathers I was
dating people that would be like
boyfriends that gave me adrenaline my
childhood circumstances I was dating
people that were children that I had to
raise I already had you know so it was
like to me as soon as I met someone who
was a father I was like it doesn't even
matter if this relationship works out
it's not about me that's exactly the
father I love that so I basically told
the girls
um a couple episodes ago that I don't
care who I get pregnant by at this point
like I'm gonna go ahead right deal yeah
you're gonna have to keep it if you can
deal with that I yeah I don't care
anymore I don't care who it is if it's
some [__] guy from a truck stop like
it just is what it is and I feel I think
your pastor trucks off days too though
you would be surprised what I I love
thick butted construction workers yeah
yeah I will never get over them give me
a stevedore a longshoreman like that is
what I like okay but here's my main
question is like do you feel do are you
having any anxiety about like how people
say there's only six good years left of
the climate like the world is
everything's people who are you Esther
what so you're not okay that's helpful
to hear you get your news in the belly
rooms but it's like yeah so we're not
too afraid about this I think we've
humans have always been like this so it
was like in the 20s they were afraid of
trains and elevators and so you know now
we're afraid of trans so now yeah so
yeah will there be no water who knows
are they going to desalinate Glaciers
like who knows I just think if you're
always thinking in terms of that you're
in like a fear addiction and I think
that the smartest people are the ones
that aren't procreating so how are any
of these problems gonna get solved but
also like like my life's been a
nightmare this baby can be born into a
[__] nightmare it's they'll you'll
deal with it can I say though oh you're
not so you're not that's that's great
for me to hear it you also help me not
be afraid of flying by saying flight
attendants don't have cancer so it's
fine so this is good
there are no cross-sectional studies yet
you we all have cancer let me just be
very clear we all have cancer you will
get cancer I think if you're constantly
thinking about the things you're afraid
of they're just going to rule your life
and I think for me it's something really
liberating happens after both of your
parents die where you're kind of like
okay now what you know and I think that
I had no interest in having kids when my
parents were alive because I already had
to take care of them I wasn't able to
break a lot of the Cycles with them
until they were gone and I was too
afraid I was gonna parents like them it
just it just didn't feel right yet and
here's another thing I'm gonna say
you're never gonna get uh pregnant
unless you're having a lot of orgasms
and staying laid down so this is the
first this is the best sex I've ever had
in my life and I truly thought I was
Barren because that's what all the men
on Reddit told me
and I went off birth control in which by
the way if you're on birth control no
judgment like now is not the time to be
negative in any capacity on birth
control for me I didn't realize how
um
much of my brain it took from me like I
was on it for so long and uh and then
when I because it tells your body you're
pregnant fine in your 20s better than
being pregnant it works for me for a
long time but I after I went off that I
kind of got like very manic like I went
off it right away I went off Prozac as
well after my parents were gone I was
like let me just like see who what my
Baseline is I've like lost track of even
who I am chemically hormonally and you
can't um basically your pheromones uh
you know you know before you marry
someone you should always go off birth
control and make sure you are still
attracted though for the same reasons
because it's like you know you smell
pheromones differently when you're
pregnant so you want to make sure that
you're still sexually attracted to the
person yeah you know before
um I talked about this in a special way
more elegantly than that so I went off
birth control and I was like oh what are
the chances that I would get pregnant
and then I started sleeping with a guy
that just was like his Kink was or
giving a woman orgasm oh not just okay
obsessed with it and can and that's what
makes you get pregnant like the being
able to have orgasms and then I would
stay laying down
you know and that's how it kind of
happened because he held you down
I mean we would joke about it we would
it's hot but so then it happened like
he's a man but you're still the holder
down early
some things can't change or just the
idea of being with someone that you care
enough about to be lying there and like
talking afterwards not just getting up
and being like wrong let me just you
know that's how I was before I was so
it's gone I will say that when I found
out you were pregnant I'm like so fully
confident in your ability to like be a
great mother and
and do like I'm I like didn't wasn't
like when my friends told me they're
pregnant they were you know like oh
totally dude I don't really like trust
your I see a lot of my friends that I
used to really look up to and I see the
way that they parent their kids and I'm
just like dude I like I mean even before
I had a kid it's just sort of there's a
great book on Hunt gather parent and
it's about you really have to let your
kids have consequences you have to let
them you can't solve problems for them
and if it's going to take them 30
minutes to try their shoe you have to
just sit there and let them do it
because if you do everything for them I
mean infantilizing a child that's
technically what the word is you know
means but you gotta let them fall you
got to let them make mistakes and I have
a really I think inability to do that
adversity has benefited all of us like I
have a good relationship with adversity
um Amanda Knox who was on when she was
oh he loved her she's the best
and the way that she would after the
Premiere at our house because she was on
my roast you know her daughter Eureka
was like walking around the yard and she
was just like letting her go letting her
walk you would turn around make sure she
was you know still okay keep walking she
wasn't like hovering over her though and
you know I see these parents to take
their kids to like a playground and
they're like and this is what happened
to me too be careful don't hurt yourself
like we just don't just and I see the
kids being like why did you bring me
here yeah if it's dangerous why are you
putting fear into my head I think that
might be me because my mom was very like
she really projected all of her
anxieties onto my sister and I so I will
really have to practice like pulling
back you'll have to like even with my
dogs now I'm like you know like I'm
always just watching because then you're
just training them to be scared and then
they stop trusting you because they're
like you're the one that brought me here
yeah so just bring me to the safe place
where I can Thrive you know as women
right now like there was an article I
think it was in the Atlantic about like
women that like run businesses that are
really successful and then they have
kids and they run their kid like a
business oh [__] and they put their type
a [__] and I see all these like La moms
are like well my six-year-old is in
therapy i'm like [__] you need to be
why are you making your cake your kiss
sit on a couch bored out of his mind
it's bored you're you're no it doesn't
want to do all this [__] it doesn't want
to go to these classes it doesn't want
to play all these Sports it just wants
to play in the mud but it's also illegal
I guess now to let your kid just go
outside without watching it so I think
there's no depends where yeah that's why
I want to raise kids in the Philippines
still a wild wild west I just think it's
like it's hard to like conflating like
love and micromanaging or two separate
things but I think you just gotta like
give it play to the top of its
intelligence yeah I feel like we were
let out a little too much though as kids
I mean my brothers we were bad things
that happened to me were inside the
house same I was the safest when I was
outside on the street at night I was
just like out a lot you look baffled
Esther well I just didn't okay I have
another question about my anxiety that
I'm projecting onto you do you lose a
lot of your anxieties because you're
short
we did go over this I do agree but I
like Randy but that's like a genetic
thing thank you it's not my fault yeah
but do you now that you are pregnant
like are you having a lot more awareness
of like these toxic products and like
they say people and that that's a yes
people there is something that happens
where instantly you're just like oh I
would have put myself in this situation
a little bit longer but now I just like
right it's just you know what I mean
things start to get really clarifying
it's kind of nice products same thing it
is wild dude I was like making a
registry and I put like like some baby
powder thing my friend was like what the
[__] you can't use baby like you realize
everything
gave us like tit tumors so I think I'm
trying to find the happy medium and not
be oh because the worst thing for you is
Corazon yeah so nothing is going to be
as bad for you as that internal medicine
cabinet drug but yeah I mean we're also
breathing LA Air right you know that's
the thing like I so I like stopped doing
weed recently and I noticed while I was
getting high all those anxieties went
away and like life was a lot more
peaceful and I wasn't having those
cortisols but like I but now that I'm
off of it that stuff is kind of starting
to come back up for me so I yeah it's
just can I ask you a question about that
yeah did you find that while you were
smoking the weed the anxieties went away
and then what happened when you weren't
smoking yet
well I've read about this that weed does
cause your anxiety to get worse when you
are not high so that's what happened to
me is like when I was high no problem
yeah and then when I wasn't my tolerance
actually went down and then I needed the
weed more yeah it's like the weed needs
you to need it so it's like nothing
could have been better when I was on it
no problems no stress but then when I
was off it I was twice as angry as or
I'm sorry anxious that too
um as a kind of like rebound anxiety
yeah as I was before I even had that in
the first place so it's like the streams
were more extremes are more extreme
instead of kind of being like a little
bit anxiety all the time which is
probably the healthy way to go and did
you struggle with like having to get off
of weed because of the pregnancy are you
like happy that you're doing that I had
already gone off I had already started
to see a lot of negative consequences
like I see how people at least what they
say is that weed is good for them and
they're creative although all my friends
that are like I smoke weed to be
creative like where's the work yeah
are you sure like I just smoke weed
right jokes and you see their jokes and
you're like uh yeah they call you at
like 4 P.M on Tuesday they're like is
this work done yeah weed is like can you
stop bringing us up please
um so you know it seems to work for a
lot of people I see a lot of people that
are using it to check out they're like
it makes my relationship better it's
like just being numb in a relationship
isn't you're tolerating it you're
numbing yourself like you know so I was
kind of sort of like who do I really
admire or look up to the smoking weed
all day like Snoop like sure whatever
but for me like I think being able to
realize like all of our brains and
bodies and hormones are in traumas and
past are different and it just wasn't
working for me the way it was I was
seeing other people like yes it would
make me feel better as I was going to
sleep it made me be like I'm gonna put
my phone down and I'm just gonna listen
to these rain sounds and it's fun for
like a little bit Yeah but like it's a
lifestyle for me it actually made me
like kind of manic I felt like I didn't
sleep well at all when I would smoke
weed like I would smoke weed like it
would maybe get me to the place of being
like asleep but not out really sleeping
I think it's great for like every now
and then as a fun thing to like if it's
you have a hard time coming out of your
shell or at a party socializing but this
thing of like every day at seven o'clock
just like lighting up was like you know
and maybe I didn't figure out my sativa
Indica all of it like sativa was the one
I was doing it made me manic like this
is how fast I talk when I'm already
intense I'm already kind of like you
know have a fast moving brain and maybe
like so much more Manic and maybe like
so much more trying to socialize with
everybody I want to connect with
everybody and it was like just like too
much yeah personally I was also in a
place of grief where I needed to be
feeling my feelings and it was making me
mask the feelings I needed to feel so
then anger was coming out in weird ways
and you know and then when I would do
Indica to sleep I wasn't dreaming and I
think that dreaming is really important
to help deal with your anxieties and
release pain and future planning you
know so are you were you able to dream
on it I think I was able to dream but
then I've also read that like the sleep
you get from wean is not really
like efficient good sleep or something
yeah I think it's just like being
dependent on anything yeah it was where
I start to go this one same that's what
was scaring me and then like reading
about how it's bad for your brain or
whatever but now that you what was the
bat what is that it just bad it's like
supposedly like ages your brain faster
but so now that you are pregnant you
can't do the weave like what do you have
this is like what I'm dealing with now
like just in general like what do you go
to to like
kick back or like relax or look like do
you have anything that helps back to my
workaholism dude it's like it was always
there My Favorite Drug dude kick back
write a book it kind of sounds great you
know I'm just starting businesses every
night instead
um you know I think like I'm really glad
I did it you know um but I think for you
gotta like look at your rock bottom like
my rock bottom was kind of like I felt
like I made all this progress to make
more noise
um I I know it's good are those back
remember what were those videos where
they
um I think for me it's like I worked so
hard to be able to have like boundaries
in my life and to be able to hold them
and go like oh I I can have love for
this person I can have respect for this
person but this isn't an everyday friend
this is like a our proximity of where we
Thrive is like here or like a family
member that's like this is like a twice
a year family member or whatever and I
felt like I was really able to be in
acceptance
um of people things certain business
Arrangements that were like a healthy
distance that was best for both of us
without any judgments without you know
and then I was smoking weed and all of a
sudden I was like what it was just
people that I had not talked to in four
or five years I'm like fly in Stay With
Me I was just like I have no it's not
not having self-respect it's just I I
have this weird short-term memory with
weed and then all of a sudden I'm saying
yes to things I shouldn't be saying yes
to I just like let a lot of not guards
down like I you know but just uh I got
myself in a lot of jams yeah smoking
weed I was just like I feel like I've
like done so much work on myself to like
learn all these tools of how to take
care of myself and have the life I want
and then I smoke weed and I'm just not
whatever I have no access to those all
this work totally yeah I loaned a lot of
people for everyone that was able to get
their debt paid off when I was stoned
like good friends she cannot remember
who you are good job couldn't tell you
but like I think for me there was just
like a little too much like of living in
the moment I think there's like a happy
medium it made me a little too chill in
a way that wasn't like protecting myself
I'm also I'm not a fun high hang I'm I'm
one of those it's okay so Alex Jones did
say there was an island he did say it so
like I'm that guy when I'm stoned you
know so I think it's just like I'm
putting together pieces I went hard into
the Scientology maritime law thing I
like what is their marriage well like so
there's no laws on international waters
right like billionaires always want to
be on Yachts because they can pretty
much do anything on International Water
what the [__] do they want to do out
there if kids and drugs and you know
farming organs I don't know why have you
not heard of the lady who was um
um doing abortions in on her ship
because it was legal for her to do so
because it was International water so
she was providing women this service but
couldn't she just do that in La no
because a lot of countries are you know
it's illegal so she was taking this boat
around which I thought yeah oh wow
that's wild yeah so it's like
Scientology the way they're able to
operate their cult is basically to be on
international waters they can have kids
on international waters and like that's
where they do it all and I
so upset like I think that the weed
addiction turns I get into some justice
addiction where like the grandiose uh
um feelings of grandiosity we're like
I'm the I'm finding Shelley mascap like
I'm where is she though by the way who
cares no way that she's not the Serena
Joy of this Opera
I hope she's in the bottom of the
[__] ocean with the Titanic billion
I'm sorry I can't stop laughing about
that when billionaires off themselves
that way it just notice there were no
women in that that no no no
women did bolt it tight it was like you
literally there's a video of women just
bolting and being like ah [__] idiot
um I just think that no billionaire I
don't mean to laugh at someone's death
it's just there was a kid on it whatever
but
um that no billionaire ever became a
billionaire by not putting kids in
Cobalt mines or doing something awful or
underplaying their employees so I feel
like when they off themselves in such a
hilarious way I feel like it's a service
dog well their son instead of Blink 182
content yeah so I guess I just like I I
look maybe that's how people solve
problems and change the world they get
stoned like I'm the one that's gonna
change the world but when I get stoned
I'm like I'm going to the Border I just
need to talk to them you're like the
loan forgiveness lady yeah
literally I I started buying books on
the guy that financed Hitler and I I
just was like she showed me that book
yeah
I started like really and I think that
after you lose parents you're also kind
of rudderless you're like what's my
purpose or how it's nice the Nazis I'll
take it yeah I literally was like I'll
get to the bottom of that you know who
no one's talked about Hitler you think
every idea you have is so original and
mind-blowing like I had this journal
like I would smoke weed fall asleep and
I just drive would like like lay with a
you know a pad of paper and a pen and I
would like Scribble stuff and I would
think it was the most genius [__] yeah
ideas I would wake up the next morning
it would be like men and women are
different I'd be like cool
have you guys heard I think it's called
lymphocyte immunization therapy no so
it's what they give it's what they do
with women who have repeated
miscarriages so they basically take so
on a cellular level the woman is
rejecting the baby because of she's
technically on a cellular level
rejecting the man right so they take a
bit of his white blood cells and I don't
know what they do with it but they
basically inject it into to the woman so
she has some type of
um what do you call it she has a
vaccination yeah like you're vaccinating
yourself with your man's like white
blood cells and they do this for
obviously women who are in in vitro and
who are getting repeated miscarriages
but I was thinking you know how we were
talking about the last time where you're
like someone if someone's not a
biological match and your body just sort
of like rejects them
a lot of times that means you're related
to the bottom of Esther and Dave me and
Dave like there's a breath issue
well all you eat is Pinkberry
but all you eat is candy from Japan I
was thinking maybe you could do this and
see on a cellular level if you start to
not reject each other but I like his
body smell so that's good right that's
good yes that is good but I the breath
but you guys need to hire someone to
chew you need to hire someone to chew
your food has he been eating your [__]
that's the problem
I hate his breath just hate your own
stem sure I feel like breath that's a
trick because I feel like also 10 years
in you stop chewing gum and you stop
kind of trying controversial question do
you love the way your [__] smells like
on a man's mouth every time or just half
the time or a quarter of the time not
everything is zero an option right zero
every time sometimes I go oh my bad
oh I had a different idea of what was
happening okay
because sometimes I think I'm fine and
then I smell their mouth and I'm just
like what [__] what is happening
do you know how much your subscriptions
are really cost absolutely not it's
terrifying I don't want to know I never
know I want rocket money to take it over
well they absolutely can do that because
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place and over 80 of people have
subscriptions they forgot about and
chances are you're like us and you're
one of them rocket money will quickly
and easily find your subscriptions for
you and for any you don't want to pay
for anymore just hit cancel and Rocket
money will cancel it for you it's that
easy my favorite thing is that rocket
money also helps you manage all your
finances in one place it automatically
categorizes your expenses so you can
easily track your budget in real time
and also get alerted if anything looks
off which is really important over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to seven
hundred and twenty dollars I can't
believe that that is so much that is so
much I'm probably spending more and not
even like I probably do that a month so
it's scary and now that we all have to
have children match Whitney we're gonna
need this money stop throwing your money
away cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
that's rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
would be less attracted to a man if he
even is like shows a little bit of
hesitation on my dirtiest thing well I
told you that I went on okay you're gay
I dated a guy and then like after the
first time we banged he started saying
it wasn't about me but he would just
like he was like oh yeah I have like a
really strong sense of smell or whatever
like he just mentioned that
and I was like I never want to [__] you
again like I don't want someone who's
like
someone that is just a beloved character
a gal in the this town
um
when I first moved to LA I met her and I
was I was just like I don't know
whatever autism or Asperger's The
Tourette's [__] I have were I it was
before I kind of knew how to just like
ease into a conversation I would just
say the first thing like when I first
met Samuel L Jackson when I was 24 at
the Friars Club Roast I literally
introduced myself and went how much
money do you have like I love that and
he answered too answer by the way I was
like it was like a Tourette's thing
where I just like I was like I don't
have that much time with this person I
don't have so much time with you how
much does he make he said he was like he
I think he said it this was a while ago
he was like 18 million but liquid right
liquid like he literally was like well
liquid like he started breaking it down
I was like this is because you were
curious totally it wasn't like to use
against him in anything no yes he didn't
know me I was just some nobody comedian
and then I kind of I and then I was like
okay you can't do that to people it's
weird and um but oh so I met this girl
that a lot of guys that I had dated she
like broke their hearts and I was like
oh sir you're a so-and-so like you know
and it wasn't mean or like mean girly I
was like so everyone in L.A is in love
with you and I dead serious wasn't
trying to be shitty I was like so what's
your secret like what is it like you
know girls a lot of times say like say
as little as possible you know there's
certain tricks right and she goes I put
Cherry chapstick up my [__]
she just said Katy Perry
um that would throw me into a beasty
yeasty so fast yeah because I was like
so you're just messing up the bell curve
for everybody right so no one has the
smelly [__] it's just compared to your
cherry chapstick because there's also
the Nostalgia yeah I think you tell us
afterwards who it is yeah okay yes I can
I mean should we try I feel like my
[__] would not take I did the medicated
one and no one liked it
um why do they even make that Bliss Max
the black cherry chapstick that's just
like it smells like [__] actually
um but yeah she would just like put it
on her [__] lip so a guy would go down
and smell it it makes sense I just take
one of the Paltrow's vagina Kindle and I
just rub them
if you don't like it anyway
this was like very traumatic like when I
was very insecure and or would only date
guys that I felt like I had to earn
their approval who cares but I would use
like the deodorant like secret or
whatever and for whatever reason he went
to lick my armpit and I would always
watch guys out of the corner of my eye
what they were doing like even if I was
kissing a guy I'd be like my eyes would
always be like half open you know and he
went to lick my armpit and I just
watched it well
[Laughter]
yeah so deodorant all that kind of stuff
I don't I don't know but I definitely if
I'm gonna hook up with like I'll wash
and yeah I'm a scrubber quick yeah you
have to exfoliate that and you have to
really get in there because toilet paper
will get balled up oh I know Big J has a
funny joke about that it goes when you
go down on a girl and it looks like she
has like it's like a GI Joe cigarette
because sometimes in the flaps yeah
you'll be like literally I'm
experimenting with new toilet papers
because I'm trying to find one that
doesn't do that well toilet paper you're
supposed to Pat you're not supposed to
rub that's the other thing are you
sexually active during this pregnancy
sex is
better when you're pregnant there's so
much blood flow it's wild what it's wild
you can I I I've just never been able to
have orgasms very easily why are bananas
coming in here what is it what part of
the show is this
thank you
did you just hear the bananas have
radiation all of them you're gonna roll
your eyes you're gonna roll your eyes
I'm exhausted in general at that no I I
believe I'm so I'm just I'm I'm at a
loss but you'd have to eat you'd have to
eat so many okay that's me though I eat
two Bananas a Day
at once well you're embalmed you
shouldn't look this young I mean maybe
that's why
oh my God tell me more about this I
don't I've literally known they call me
ho Rogan for a reason
um I don't know who was talking about it
there was someone talking about nuclear
energy or no it was RFK Jr I think when
he was on Rogue he was talking about
radiation and things and I guess there's
some bananas I don't know why does he
have a shot at being present no
you don't think no he is Connor from
succession he has that chance
he has that chance I don't know right
there there's no chance so I said about
Trump
I feel like I I'm standing by this even
though I love I love the Kennedys I just
watched a whole DocuSign
um they're like the original Kardashians
Oh Kennedy is the original Kris Jenner
like it's teeth instead of ass so
awesome also rfk's dad Bobby is the
hottest Kennedy in my opinion right
right he was assassinated yeah yes the
second to be assassinated yeah I think
there's something interesting about
someone who's like just asking a bunch
of questions and who is totally like
like the CIA is a criminal Enterprise
here's what they've done he was a lawyer
I mean he sued Monsanto I don't think
people want but he's not a politician
which I think people like about him I oh
RFK do you guys know that I met a lawyer
Ted Kennedy and my great uncle's funeral
you did was there my great uncle was a
ambassador to India he was a famous
economist John uh F oh wait no John not
John Kennedy um
white John Galbraith oh that he's famous
yeah you know there's a comedian whose
cousin you know Earl skates yes yeah
he's a skeko his first cousin is RFK Jr
and you know the skekle story the rant
rant rant what's wrong the murder in
Greenwich no I don't know it's a murder
thing the Kennedys the one thing I will
say about the Kennedy is a lot of
catastrophes seems like you guys the
common denominator to you guys no that's
true I've heard this it's like the
Marilyn Monroe thing the the
chappaquitic it seems like you guys are
chaotic they were raised like under like
the patriarch of the family like wanted
them to be Risk Takers and bold and so
like that is their energy and I don't
know like they're you're not wrong it's
just it's a lot of debt I mean the what
was the the guy that died in the plane
crash assassinations probably don't
count but it seems like a lot of drunk
accidents but there was a lot of
alcoholism in the family and I think
they are like we're sober but there's a
lot of feuds within like there's the
sister who's against him coming out
against it's a lot of like infighting
yeah they seem like a they're rough with
each other how much money do they have
not as a Kardashian like as you but
we'll get there with the Kardashians you
think so yeah also there's gonna be
murders and Scandals no I think that
like in the future once the matriarch
goes I think we'll see feuds are you
kidding we're already
I here's the thing I have a new take on
the Kardashians like imagine you're
Kourtney Kardashian and your little
sister is Kim and she's always in the
spotlight like I don't know if you're
watching the new season but I just I
think that we will get more kennedy-like
from them I'm wearing a good American
jumpsuit it's I get Americans so good
skim's amazing I love no complaints I am
a consumer of everything they make
I vow what's that I I like the
businesses they've built and I don't and
I like that their bodies look like their
bodies like I you know my in my
formative years as a teenager I was
looking at like Kate Moss on the cover
of magazines which I think was no I
agree with it despicable what they did
for like body dysmorphia is amazing like
Kim being on the cover of magazines was
like yeah I have cellulite who cares
yeah she's like amazing I did do a lot
of like BBL like but they don't hide
that right I think people do that and
then they then they got really skinny
they do a lot of like it's I think it's
kind of hard on people like had but it's
going back and forth what I'll say the
only thing I'll say about that and this
isn't but it is good don't know enough
about it and it's not I don't know if we
have any metrics of causality
um I think all the stuff existed before
them Etc if they're not making money off
these diet products some guy's going to
yeah because someone's gonna there's
always gonna be diet culture there's
always going to be women hating their
bodies like it's like with and without
so I don't know I think that like they
do model this like shamelessness it's
just like get yours yeah you know and
you know I don't know I think it's kind
of like it's business it's capitalism
like we're mad at everyone that makes a
lot of money selling [__] yeah
he had the cutest mouth ever which I
like about it she just has these cute
little teeth she's I just think Jackie
Kennedy as a first as like a young first
lady we're not talking about it enough I
don't think we're talking enough about
this obsession with Marilyn Monroe
instead of the woman that she blatantly
slept with her husband in front of this
is a blondes versus brunette yeah as old
as time she is a button she's my mom my
mom dropped a meatball on her shoe she
was serving she was over at my
grandparents house and my mom my
grandmother was like you have to meet
them so she made my mom the
um like server of the food and my mom
was so nervous that she she like dropped
and it was like not it was like a
perfectly matched shoe
yeah she was like super Chic with the
forehead and it looks odd at this angle
um tricky well his looked even worse
yeah but yeah I mean it is weird when
you look back and you're like look I
have an obsession with Marilyn Monroe
too but we're just like she just Jackie
was in the front room she's like no
Jackie wasn't there oh really she didn't
go even shadier she knew not to go she
see I always thought that the Marilyn
Monroe JFK Affair was just like us as a
country like fantasizing about what
could have been but it's it seems like
it was real very real I cannot believe
that it seems like fan fiction to me did
you see the movie Blind oh my God from
the abortions there was literally a shot
from the fetuses it was I would let her
dot why can't we let that movie also is
based on a fiction historical fiction
yeah so that's it's just trauma porn
yeah but it's very well executed like
it's it was incredible interesting well
made her performance is amazing but the
one thing about it
Marilyn Monroe didn't have a Spanish
accent like Anna diarma she did have an
American one either nothing she said
made any sense and all these quotes on
Instagram she didn't say any of this
[__] and the [__] she did say she sounds
like an [__] like don't show up until
you're ready to show up make him wait
two hours you're like this person's an
[__] what are we doing also his wife
is waiting for him get there yeah
do it and get this over with
um but it was remember when you're a
Confluence of your two favorite when Kim
Kardashian wore Marilyn Monroe that was
weird that was a huge deal I feel like
that was like a wild week for you it was
so exciting I didn't like deal with that
oh my God that was just like the most
thrilling a moment in American culture
and the fact that people were hating on
it I'm like you guys don't get it like
this is so important who cares it's a
why not this is exactly what they want
us to do she's a genius she's a PR
genius I know and it's only honoring
Marilyn like what should Marilyn's dress
just be hidden in some Museum nobody's
gonna go to like I thought it was well
executed wasn't it at a Ripley's Believe
It or Not yeah nobody goes there it did
Ripley pretty bad after who is your
dream person that Kim should date
I feel like you're really good at coming
up with who's someone well I liked the
rumors about her dating van Jones
because I was like oh let's let's have
her lean even further into her like
lawyerly political yeah yeah yeah thing
but I also could see her doing really
well with a big athlete what did you
think of again the what what did you
think about the Tom Brady rumor he's not
not it yeah he's not it for me I feel
like Pete Davidson I felt like that was
gonna go on long I did too but Dave told
me I was crazy I thought that was gonna
be it by the way he went you brought him
up on the episode that just came out
yeah and then he went into the hospital
for mental health issues you predicted
another one oh no I did not mean to my
Powers I am so sorry did you say
something that he was gonna date yeah
oh yeah oh perfect even more encouraging
it makes sense then he checked himself
a lot of the time he's getting ready to
talk about someone something wild like
Annie Broadway Leota two days later dead
like it always comes out these days
yeah cocaine bear was his last movie I
do think it was weird like when remember
when Pete Davidson was like dating all
those famous women
and everyone's like he's got a big dick
he does but isn't that imagine if we
were like like her [__] is huge no what
if her like Emma Stone is a small [__]
I'm next like it's just like weird how
we do that well you know what it was it
was because I think guys were guys are
like looking at them they're like how is
this guy getting girls there's got to be
something that we're missing who was
Ariana did it and Ariana did the point
the term big dick energy I think
anyone's dick is big around her but
but is that a stretch yeah cause one of
my most petite friends has the most
massive [__] really she is I'm right
here
she's even smaller than you she is she
maybe weighs like 90 pounds and she was
like kalai Lama size queen and not
because this is not a choice I'm making
like it can just swallow I have the
biggest [__] always figured if you were
small you must have is that's my
daughter says no she's like no like I
need massive dick because I feel like my
[__] is a very wide runway and I need
it to be filled yeah so who was I
talking to a oh someone we know who said
they have a really deep [__]
um I have I have a tilted uterus yes I
have a very shallow exactly it's
uncomfortable for me past a certain size
yeah like they I might have that thing
Meghan Trainor has or it's it's not like
I have a small business because it's
just the way my uterus is that's in your
vagina everyone yeah you want to come to
your house I mean after having a kid I
don't know I don't even know I think I
don't know do you think in terms of like
gun to your head are you like childbirth
want to do I have I've been lucky enough
to to watch both C-sections emergency
C-sections regular C-sections and um
live birth for myself I would hope that
if I can do live birth that I will do
that yeah because the C-section is my
God like it really scarred me watching
them especially the emergency one and
also yeah but also like the um you get
to go home much sooner when you do live
birth it's just also better for the baby
it's just like gives more you know
what's so weird I met I went to Ben this
is weird I went to Ben glebe's party
that wasn't the weird part of the
running for president yeah and rally I
Gotta Give Ben this he does I laugh very
hard around bengaly yeah he's so [__]
funny he tells me stories that I'm like
crying laughing he is hilarious but I
went to his his house for a party and
there was a woman in a hat and he was
like oh let me introduce you have you
met her yet and I didn't know who it was
and she turned around and it was Ricky
Lake and I went oh my God I've seen you
give birth and she did not care for it
walked by me and I was like oh because
she had she made a documentary uh The
Business of Being Born all about how
hospitals will Four Seasons we'll Force
C-sections to like move you through the
system faster and um
and that but she was not the first
person in the movie that I [__] saw I
was a waitress in New York and the
really badass Midwife that they had on
there they showed her birth and she was
like really cool she she was a crazy
girl like a Brooklyn [__] but she and
they watched and she had like a really
crazy painful home birth and she was
like I was like weirdly Starstruck when
I met her but it's like you don't I was
like how do you tell someone yeah I've
seen her put them in your [__] stretch
I mean there's not a how and it's just
you don't but I did look I'll tell you I
struck out with rookie lake so Ricky
but you did put yourself out there okay
I seen you in a tub I should have done
known only fans I know someone who
number one she tore in 13 13 inches she
had to get the Lila's short friend
she had to get the vaginal um
Rejuvenation thing and she went to the
doctor that does it and he said
size-wise would you like to go back to
16 18 or 21. ew that's disgusting that
is that like a gauge of like the
earrings to those little stretchers I I
I don't know what the logic is on that
no that is so gross do they do you guys
think there's a huge difference between
16 and 18. they do and I'm going to tell
you this because I talk about this with
my guy friends a lot like they're like
they're so gross and I'm like okay fair
they're mostly autistic yes severely but
like the reason that younger women I
this is my theory when guys [__] younger
girls and they think they're more wet
than when they [__] someone like more
age-appropriate I'm like it's because
the age-appropriate woman is like why am
I [__] this loser the 18 year old the
wet is tears yeah and the young girl is
turned on because you're a fetish to
them because you're an old loser like so
that's hot to them your guy friends are
not a fetish Chef no if you can't get a
woman who's 40 wet with your personality
yes yes they're a little bit gusted by
the fact that they're [__] you no
anyways back to birth are you scared
like what how are you terrified because
I feel like I'd be like just keep it in
me forever like I'm too scared it's I
will once you start seeing on sonograms
now you see their face like I'm like I
want this thing I want to see this now
like it's just once it's you know in you
and you see him on the sonogram you're
like let's go it's got feed it's got
hands like now I'm just like excited to
see this little idiot
um but it's terrifying I know that our
bodies know what to do but I am fine
with the okay you're 40 you might have
to do a C-section that might just be the
safest thing and you're going to be
editing the road still
and then so I'm like I'm fine either way
but I'm very Pro epidural and very Pro
doctors I'm not having a baby in a
bathtub I'm Pro alive baby yeah I dated
a pediatric anesthesiologist who worked
in Portland and he said he they would
lose five six babies a day to umbilical
cord around the neck from people having
births at home like what yeah if you can
have a staff of people there and a
doctor on staff and do it at home like
godspeed but I'm big online it happened
to my friends uh her like old roommate I
lost a baby that way having birth at
home yeah but the great news is that
when you do it someone gives you a check
from in a trophy like nothing nobody
gets points no one's like cool you're
better than us you know what I mean so
I'm uh I'm just gonna like cross that
bridge and I get to it but I'm just
going like I'll be on drugs yeah yeah
I'm okay with that I'm like I get I'll
just get it I'll be on drugs I can't
imagine even having a birth plan that's
like
towards natural give me the epidural
just because it's also it's like women
used to die and but I've also like
endured enough trauma in my life I've
endured a lot of pain like this doesn't
have to be a new trauma and the way you
enter the world is apparently I remember
this is when I stopped working with this
trauma therapist because she was like
okay we've done so much work on your
adult traumas your childhood traumas now
let's address
um the trauma of you being born and I
was like um I've done this work but it
is for real dude come out you go from
being warm to being cold if the doctor
holds you upside down doctors used to
spank you also doctors used to separate
babies they would you know it should go
into skin right away babies used to go
somewhere else they couldn't see their
mom and that's the one thing about the
C-section that really bumps me is I
don't want to be on such drugs that when
I first told my baby I'm like on
Percocet or some crazy [__] because it's
not just you have to watch it on only
fans that's true
um and so oh and then you have to be on
painkillers for a couple days after I
think so it's like I don't really want
that but like us being when we were born
like [__] was different and spooky well
I called my mom because I was like doing
this work
um about you know my birth and stuff and
uh I was like was my birth traumatic and
she was like Annie so my mom I'm a twin
right so I'm a twin and we were vaginal
birth which they would never do now wait
but my mom yeah my mom went in yeah
because it's it's like a high-risk
pregnancy twins don't do vaginal what
they would just it would be uh it's like
a bulldog giving birth they just have to
cut them out they cut us out but so my
mom said she went to the doctor and was
like I'm not leaving until I have these
kids like it was like I think a day
after our due date or something or
whenever it was like appropriate for
twins and so they gave her like an
epidural and then she said everything
was like seemed fine and then all of a
sudden when my dad left and there's no
cell phones or anything to go get like a
hamburger or something everyone's heart
rates went down and it was like an
emergency and yeah panicking and my dad
wasn't there and then my brother came
out and then I was breached so that
there was a doctor just in her trying to
like just me around and she said that he
was like really forceful she she had an
epidural and she could still feel it so
she was like panicking and your dad
wasn't there and my dad my dad did get
back in time for that but but you're
getting and then I came with adrenaline
cortisol right and then I come out first
and I like ingested some of the fluid so
then I was they came back in and they're
like she's having trouble breathing and
my mom's like freaking out about that
and then I was in an incubator so I was
with a twin and then for seven days I
had to be in an incubator
that's not good so that's why I'm like
this
he took him so
that's a big deal I mean it's like your
first memory of the world yeah
like even if you took in some meconium
technically the first thing you did was
eat [__] yes eat [__] and then also I
came out as first and and like this is
my best feature hi guys but um and I was
probably Finger by the doctor we've been
through this like a to Firkin
um but yeah and then like you know that
must have been so like and then my fam
the like I my family was probably really
like scared and upset too so and then
you're just being bathed in those
chemicals and stuff so it's like it's
like most people don't have time to get
through their childhood trauma their
adult trauma their Trauma from this
morning or yesterday but I just I'm sort
of like how do I make this as copacetic
as possible and bringing my ego into it
being like I'm not gonna use any
epidural so that I can tell everyone I'm
tough like I don't think anyone's you
know gives a [__] you know how can I
make sure this is like smooth and like
yeah I have as few surprises as possible
like I have friends that are like oh
this one friend of mine her dude was
filming and she tore and the baby gave
birth tore he said I'm no longer
attracted to you after watching you give
birth which is the thing him disgusting
but also women spend so much time trying
to not poop when they're giving birth
that's another thing so I'm kind of like
only certain people are allowed in the
room I'm not gonna like I'm gonna [__]
I'm gonna the goal is to take a show
because when you push you're put you
yeah like that and then eating is what
gets things moving you know they say
that the thing that induces labor the
fastest is sex
but yeah like I just I Know Myself and I
know that I'm gonna be like taking care
of everyone to make sure everything well
it's okay and like you know so I think
I'm like I'm just my birth plan is
really just making sure there's only a
couple people really allowed in like Can
I submit my resume I think I will not
become less attracted to a few [__] I
swear and like she does that [__] level
too
and they're saying you shouldn't do as
many baths like they would take them to
do baths all the time you don't need all
these baths like I don't know and then
there's like big baby whereas they're
trying to sell you all this [__] yeah
just to be like and you need to collect
these cells as soon as you give birth
you need to cut the umbilical cord to
put these in a bag yeah but no I'm the
reason I have money is because I don't
fall for it because you know what I'm
saying I don't yeah they're just like
you need to put your placenta in a
smoothie and snort it into and you're
just like no thanks dude I don't want
any of this [__] so a lot of is playing
is playing defense against people that
are trying to prey on the fact that
you're scared you know
okay I would just would you ever adopt I
was looking into adoption before this I
always I do feel like having your own
kid is like buying a dog from a breeder
that's still raw it's so not me like I
was looking at um I was looking at well
if the kid comes out and bites you it'll
be like you it's just
and there is a friend of mine who was
dealing with her kid it won't stop
biting
adopted no oh no and I also it's like
the way you are when you're pregnant is
gonna decide what kind of epigenetic
epigenetic imprinting your kid gets so I
am like there is just this imperative
like when you're pregnant you're just
like I'm calm like I'm not the things
that used to like Adrenalize me and
freak me out like I just had this really
rough business situation I'm like all
right
like there's something kind of nice
about it there's some kind of like like
grounding about it there's something
it's also like really nice to not think
about yourself all the time something
sort of you don't realize like oh I can
think about something else or someone
else I do see that in some of the the
um the women that I see that don't have
kids where I'm like and I think that
about us I've said this about us too
it's like we're like like naturally
we're supposed to have kids at this
point at our age as animals and it's
like we're not we're supposed to be
focusing on something else that's not
ourselves the way I treat my dog I'm
like oh I should have had a kid like
okay that's a question I wanted to ask
you because we ask each other this all
the time
um do you think that you love your kid
more than your dogs
it's a different kind of love it will be
a conditional love
whereas the love for dogs is
unconditional perfect answer yeah I I
don't know I think I don't think there's
anything wrong with conditional love
between humans and I don't mean my
love's gonna go away but it's like you
don't get to talk to me like that and
you've lost the privilege of being able
to talk to me my dogs never lose the
privilege of being around me my dog my
dog's never true my dogs never get
punished for something they never you
know because they're also trained and
they they just want to make you happy
but the problem is kids like they want
to test you that's part of their job
that's was part of our job when we were
teenagers girls and we were [__] to
our moms we were testing them you know
you have to test your parents you have
to make sure are you safe can I trust
you the biggest thing that I'm dealing
with right now is do I tell them about
Santa him sorry I'm sorry I'm not he's
not a they yet
um sorry this is La I have a pitch
please when I was babysitting this is
what the mom did and I loved it
um you talk about Santa like it's a
story and we play pretend that Santa
comes okay it's like a fun story and
it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
when everyone else was trying to tell me
that Santa wasn't real it made me
appreciate all the effort my parents put
into making the sounds over the roof
like there are a lot of horrible things
that happened to me as a child and that
was my one oh it was happening it was
just so sweet my brothers and I would
all go up to my older brother's room and
my mom would put Hershey Kisses up the
stairway going down and my parents
bawled out on Christmas like I was very
lucky I was so spoiled on Christmas and
it was like we'd go down and we'd get
our stockings first and bring them into
our parents room and my mom would like
try to disguise her hand like my mom
went all out like as much as my mom like
ignored me in weird places in my life
she like I think one place that it that
there's room for improvement with the
Santa of it all is using it as a
surveillance tool to manipulate kids
being like if you're naughty or not
you're gonna get more presents you're
gonna really appreciate it
I don't want to help on the Shelf the
elf's watching you oh you don't have to
you don't have to use that storyline my
parents never did the naughty none of
that I didn't even know about that until
I came to America Santa just existed you
guys you know what they do with with one
of my with my nieces in law one of
Todd's babies they'll go the cops are
coming she's no like I mean thank you
but I know a friend of mine um uh one
time uh was walking along the beach and
um Mary McCormick and uh she her kids
were like we want to go to the beach and
she went honey the ocean is broken
and they're like oh man she's like next
time
um but uh I I as a kid I guess I had the
opposite experience because I feel like
my parents lied to me so much that it
was just like another weird lie that I'd
like to figure out because I'd be like
he comes down the chimney like we don't
have a chimney [__] and then it was all
like don't talk to strangers and don't
and I was like so there's a man coming
into our house in the middle of the
night it spooked me and then I also was
like I think kids are smarter than we
give them credit for and I I found I was
like this is the same handwriting as my
dad and like at least change your
handwriting I remember with like the
Tooth Fairy feeling because my dad like
and I knew you know like you just get to
the age where like oh this is all thick
but you want to believe it and my dad
lifted my head up to put to take my
tooth and I was like still up but I was
like pretending to be asleep and then I
remember chasing him because my dad
would walk to the train station like
chased him down and I was like I was
like crying and he's like what and I was
like the tooth Fair only left me 50
cents like a half dollar I was like I
thought I'd get more
is a cheap bastard
um just kidding
um but it was like but I remember that
like feeling of like it just felt like a
loss of Innocence it didn't feel I
didn't feel like the full betrayal of it
I don't know why it's also I uh I also
don't want to have the kid who goes to
school tells everyone that's gonna be my
kid I remember you I didn't tell people
I did not ruin it for other people are
we sure oh for sure I wouldn't I was not
an [__] like I knew that some people
thought it was real but I never believe
in Santa no I did but I remember I was
smarter than that and I was like mom or
your parents didn't really sell it yeah
I I was just like tell me Mom just
[__] tell me like first she started
by opening up about how the tooth is
great sloppy for cursing no wait why I
never had a formal conversation there
was never a formal conversation I don't
remember what it disintegrated or
anything I think it was just like my
parents for Christmas gifts they would
just wrap up [__] around the house that
was already there so I'd be like how did
Santa get this ashtray but see my
bedroom Super Creative
um he would hang things in the backyard
on a tree and be like oh look like he
would have us do this hunt of where
Santa just dropped the presents it
wouldn't oh that's not all of them would
be under the tree he would hire my
uncles to make the sounds on the roof
okay but we didn't have money so I'd be
like can Santa bring groceries like in
November let me ask you this did you
ever do Easter egg hunts yes and you
didn't really think the Easter so I will
say this and that was so fun my most the
magical part was not that I fully
believed in this man the magical part
was the experience of knowing that maybe
you know my parents were involved but
there was this thing I could write
letter to every year that I could be
excited about because gifts would come
and we could all be together and
celebrate so it was just exciting not
because like this you know person
existed that I had full faith in and my
older brother like in my version you
could have that it's cute that my older
I knew before us and then like kind of
like conspired with my parents to like
keep it really fun for us so you're
saying Esther just tell the story yes
you tell the story of Santa Claus and
then the story well I don't know but it
makes poison yeah are you watch a movie
and you're like Santa's gonna come and
you just like it's like I don't know
just like play pretend but I had I've
like like to a fault that my Tourette's
of whatever of like it'd be like he goes
to every house in one night yeah it
doesn't make sense I was like that at
like six and I was just like what
there's no chimney so like I couldn't
just like and it's weird because later I
fantasy was my primary drug to cope
before like like you know eating stuff
or control issues you know you know
other family members use drugs or
alcohol mine was checking out into
fantasy wait so like maladaptive
Daydream yes that's all I did too I
would write journal entries I also think
that's why you're successful and I went
into writing I went into being an
imaginative person but it's almost like
I had the ability to dream so big
because I lived in such a fantasy world
because I wanted to check out of my
reality so hard that in the sense like
there is a level of like hate to say it
manifestation there yeah so strongly
because you that world is so comforting
you're just visualizing yeah I used to
do a weird thing where I would like I
would just imagine myself if I wasn't me
and that would make me like where I was
like I'd go like that breaks my heart I
would go like I would just go I would go
like what if I was like what if my body
was put into like my neighbors and I was
like living in my neighbor's house and
it made me like like being in my life I
always pretended I was in commercials
really like I that's so sick yeah
I know I wish I pretended more it is on
our Dental commercial
that was good money my dad would watch
Three's Company he would watch running
Dangerfield movies and I would see how
much attention the TV was getting and I
remember as a kid being like you have to
get it in the box like get on that
screen you will get his attention and I
remember that's why I became beef jerky
I remember I remember going up to my dad
at like five I don't know and being like
hey what are you reading like he's like
reading the paper and then I walked away
and I remember being like that didn't go
well like I remember being like that I
next time you got to be like hey like I
remember thinking you've gotta be more
entertaining I think purest entertainers
like there's that type of Entertainer
where it's like seeking the approval and
like just really and then there's these
pure entertainers that when you talk to
them they're like oh my parents I just
make them crack up all the time and
you're just like oh like they were just
like the little star of their family I
had to have like an achievement or a or
be injured or hurt or something it was
like it had to be something had to be on
fire or I had to be like you know but
there was no judgment around it as a kid
you're not like oh my God you're just oh
this is what I have to do to get this
love it doesn't you know and so um I
would watch commercials and I would love
watching commercial stuff like that's
where all the like families are with
food and like fridge and like I gotta
get in there like I gotta get in that
box and I remember nailed it I mean look
I remember and I would when I was alone
like eating I would eat like like cold
cuts I'd roll them up and like eat them
as if I was on camera and pretend I was
in commercials like it was a
dissociative obviously like LARPing
whatever so weird you just reminded me
of like later on in life I would do
which is funny because I know Joe now
but it was like I would like eat eggs
like I was on Fear Factor like I was
like pretend like it was gonna be really
hard to eat like practicing again
most of the people that I know that are
and that I've been able to ask about
them like people that are famous from
the public eye I'm like did you know you
were gonna be famous and they're like
yeah like I was practicing that at a
very young age not that I'm famous but I
remember like
um when I would see Billboards like we
would like drive to Roanoke Virginia
where I lived half the time and it would
say like McDonald's second exit and
everyone in the car like should we go to
McDonald's I'd be like how did that kid
get on the what the kid eating the fries
yeah I could do that yeah same so there
was this one area in my city and that
was the only area that had the big
um American Billboards and one was like
a guest billboard for guests and every
day that I would pass by it I would
imagine myself on there like over and
over that's how I felt when I saw the
news story about JonBenet Ramsey Like
That Could Have Been Me in the pageants
no one weirded out by the fact sorry
that their People magazine had a she
turns 18 today they did another thing
about her mom too it's like they're like
did she kill him because there's like an
eight Chan or something like countdown
of when JonBenet would have been 18 or
something like 18 years I just can't
even believe she it's just turning 18.
yeah she would have been 18 thing I
remember watching the documentary or one
of them maybe
um and it said uh you know we know that
she was molested because her vagina was
three times the size of an average again
that's her four-year-old friend I'm like
how did you know the size of the average
four-year-old engage how does anyone
know exactly how did how does anyone
know any of this yeah have you guys I'm
seeing that I think he's a father in his
40s who's putting his son's blood he's
getting transfused by his son's blood
because he wants to achieve he wants to
Benjamin Button himself he wants to
achieve reverse aging so he's making his
son give him his blood yeah he's like
transfusing his son's blood how old's
the son have you
um 18 or in his like when is this your
plan
is harvesting who uh I don't think this
is a real thing
I mean I don't think this is a uh I
don't think it works yeah I don't think
this works I think that's more of the
17 years 17 year old son he's a tech
billionaire sure sure a man who spends
two million dollars a year to look 18.
he doesn't look 18. he doesn't blurry oh
my god let's see him and the sun's fine
with it he looks like he's in his 40s he
doesn't look like he's reverse agent he
just looks like the guy who's gone a lot
of people [__] nap dude facelift
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Young Blood Robert figured it out yeah
he looks so he spends he spends 2
million a year on his anti-aging routine
it's not just the transfusion so he like
works out a certain way I kind of like
that men have Eating Disorders embodied
wow I kind of like that guys hate
themselves now and they're like doing
Botox and doing all this beauty [__] and
we're kind of like ah like I don't know
I I it's I I we've always had to live
like this and be worried about aging so
I don't know I'm kind of fine with it
it feels like it's like evening out the
playing field a little bit well Whitney
thank you so much for doing this oh my
gosh thanks for having this baby for us
yeah it's like it's it's and also I
don't think your life's over when you
have a kid I think you like immediately
start organizing your time better and
being more efficient with your time and
I just I don't know I was like running
out of [__] to talk about I hope you
know how Annie you said that pregnancy
is um contagious yeah like I think I'm I
I know it's honestly like I'm okay just
getting inseminated by whoever and just
being like all right [__] it who cares
it's like I have so many girlfriends
that did that they either did a
surrogate or they just got a donor and
they did it on their own or whatever I
think I want to do it on my own this is
fun it's super I'm inspiring it's not
that I'm already halfway through I'm
doing it so that I'll give birth in
December so I'll like perfect I'll be
gone anyway you know what I mean like I
just mean it's gonna be downtown you
have to come up with your Santa thing
quick yeah and I just I've just been
working way more efficiently you know
it's not that hard and I I just I don't
know it feels like it's like inevitable
for all of us well you were like
like six months ago you're like it seems
archaic for me to have my own kids yeah
I did I didn't get it I was like but
that seemed crazier so I was like no
it's good I can employ a woman to have
this I'm redistributing the wealth I
should have someone else do it like and
I think I did I think that we have to
say a lot of things
um
I had to say a lot of things that I
believed at the time that I think were
rooted in my insecurity of thinking oh
well I could never have money anyway
right so I had to turn it into like oh
it's okay guys we shouldn't be having
kids because I didn't think I could well
my Todd's parents are really like
putting on the Press like when are you
gonna defroster I'm like I just froze
them so I keep telling probably get
pregnant naturally though yeah I think
so too but I keep telling his mom like
you're the surrogate you have it I want
one of your eggs dude I'm just gonna
bang it out this year I'm just gonna
roll the dice you would love it I I just
want to like own a home first I don't
know I just don't think I like have
enough equity to have a kid right now
if you're a construction worker and
you're thick butted
I think there's so many like sorry I
will wrap up but it's like I've like
people reach out they're like I have a
bassinet do you want it I have this
thing will you take it will you take
this crib like I haven't paid for a
thing I haven't bought anything so far
like will you take the stroller please
like I don't need it anymore it's like
the village starts to appear and women
start like I mean there's a lot of like
crazy advice you start getting but like
people start being like hey do this do
this go to this person go to this Louie
told me about people Louis was like he's
like you should definitely have a kid
he's like he he's like there's an old
saying every kid is born with a loaf of
bread under their arm or something like
it always you like wealth comes with the
kids somehow interesting I remember uh
Donald Glover like uh Childish Gambino
sorry remember when he was like rapping
and doing really well and doing stand-up
and on community and on whatever and was
like super super successful but was just
you know doing that and then all of a
sudden he was on Fallon someone sent me
a clip they didn't even know that I knew
him of him singing Redbone shirtless
sounded like Marvin Gaye meets Janice
Joplin meets like he like sound
incredible and I just texted him I was
like uh what happened like it was just
like a completely different creative
Direction and like I had chills when he
was singing and he was like I had a kid
wow what yeah and it like aimed his art
it just yeah I think I think for your
thing you start going like I have a
higher purpose and that like I need to
change the world now because I'm
bringing a kid into this world that
might not have water and it might be
unjust and you know it's like I'm like
what do I really want to say who do I
really want to be like what am I really
going to put out there like how am I
Really Gonna
operate on a daily basis like I think it
changes like focuses you up maybe a
little bit or not I know a lot of male
Comics that have kids that I didn't know
they had kids for eight years that I've
seen them performance I get a lot of you
know I'm sure it doesn't do that forever
you also see the moms that are like the
Kathy ack moms that are like don't do it
unless you're sure and then you're like
oh yeah but those are the moms that's so
funny those are the moms that are like
my kid is impatient and controlling and
has anger issues I'm like yeah sounds
like you
all right Wendy well thank you and um if
everyone hasn't yet they should
definitely watch her special jokes on
Netflix it's so funny
um and anything else we should be
checking out your podcast which loving
the fans TV only fans TV we did I I took
a break from the podcast and I'm back I
don't know yeah for now we'll see
um but uh I just I'm out of things to
say uh and I kind of just need a break
for myself and I had like a little bit
of a business thing so I'm airing ad
free episodes now for a little while
having a lot of porn stars on they have
a lot of wisdom so much wisdom I love
that and there's no weird shame when
you're asking stuff you know it's like
you're walking on eggshells there's
different people to podcasts yeah
they're like put a beauty blender in
your [__] to have sex on your period
you're like damn that was helpful and
then yeah the roast of me and the
roasterberg Chrysler uh which Annie was
on um of TV it's totally free um we'll
be doing more roasts on there
um and I don't know what else you could
I mean just like baby on board
coming soon what a trip you have to do a
pregnancy special I'm doing I'm shooting
one in September yeah you have to
comedians are the only people that are
like I want to work when I'm pregnant
like I want to show everybody like it's
just it is weird because it's the one
job it's like a good job to have while
pregnant yeah because you have stuff to
say about it yeah I think it's good to
show people like your life's not over
when you're pregnant and also like the
guys are just their wives are pregnant
they're just out why can't you just stay
home and lie in bed why do you feel like
go do stand-up I don't know so yeah I'm
just gonna knock one out and uh in
September because it's just like there's
stuff that I need to if I don't say it
now there's no point in saying it next
year you know and who knows I might die
in childbirth oh my God maybe you sound
like me
maybe you guys thank you so much for
watching and we will see you next week
with a brand new episode we love our
Whitney love you we love you guys
[Music]
thank you